monsieur le pain vous êtes un homme
politique connu
vous avez été syndicaliste étudiant puis
vous avez servi comme volontaire en
indochine comme officier parachutiste
après quoi vous avez été élu en 1956 à
27 ans je crois le plus jeune député de
france sous l'étiquette de l'union de
défense des commerçants et des artisans
vous avez renoncé momentanément à votre
mandat parlementaire pour servir à
nouveau en algérie comme officier au 1er
régiment étranger parachutiste et vous
avez été élue une seconde fois
l'assemblée nationale sous l'étiquette
du centre national des indépendants
d'antoine pinay aujourd'hui vous êtes
président du front national et candidat
à la présidence de la république
cela étant il y à tous candidats il y
aura un élu pensez vous que votre
candidature puisse être autre chose
qu'une candidature de principe c'est le
peuple français qui va répondre à cette
question
c'est lui qui après avoir soupesé les
programmes et après avoir jugé les
hommes décidera de la décision finale et
il est bien évident que ce choix il le
fera avec sérieux après avoir réfléchi
et sans passer par les intermédiaires
habituels de l'opinion très directement
et ses salles avantages de la campagne
présidentielle c'est qu'elle établit un
contact direct entre l'homme et ses
idées et les électeurs et les électrices
vous savez les sondages les pronostics
les prévisions dans la mesure où ils
sont parfaitement détaché de tout
intérêt je n'y crois pas beaucoup parce
que je voudrais vous citer un exemple
quand j'ai été élu j'ai débuté en 1956
personne ne pronostiquaient la victoire
des 53 députés de mon groupe politique
et alors qu'on pronostique et au
contraire que
les gaullistes allait faire un assez bon
score dans mon secteur électorale il
passait de 130 mille voix à 14000 c'est
dire que l'opinion des français peut sur
les hommes changer et que c'est payant
pour cela qu'il y à une élection
présidentielle et qu'ils vont pouvoir
juger les politiques les trois politique
dans le fond qui leur sont proposées
celle de la majorité
défendu par monsieur chaban delmas
giscard d'estaing et royer et celles de
l'opposition socialo communistes défendu
par monsieur mitterrand et celle en
quelque sorte de l'opposition nationale
c'est à dire la mienne autour du
programme de salut public que je
préconise vous êtes un homme de droite
vous professez des idées de droite et
c'est une originalité de votre part et
pourtant vous êtes un homme du peuple
eh bien je crois qu'il n'y a pas
d'incompatibilité du tout entre la
droite et le peuple au contraire et je
suis bien sûr un homme du peuple je suis
un breton qui est né d'un père marin
pêcheur et d'une mère paysanne
j'ai fait mes études comme boursier et
je suis un français comme tous les
autres c'est-à-dire un homme qui est
salarié qui est responsable d'une
entreprise qui est père de famille et
par conséquent je connais toutes les
difficultés toutes les angoisses
quelquefois et aussi tous les espoirs
les espérances des français je crois que
je suis autant et peut-être plus qu'un
autre capable de les interpréter
politiquement la droite fait souvent
référence à la défense des valeurs
traditionnelles
un autre candidat que vous même
s'attache à défendre semble-t-il valeurs
traditionnelles c'est monsieur jean
royer oui écoutez je dois vous dire que
sans parler de la personnalité de
monsieur royer probablement forte
m'étonne encore qu' ils l'affirment
vraiment d'une manière qui est un petit
peu insistante je vous assure que moi je
n'ai pas besoin de dire je suis honnête
parce que c'est la malhonnêteté qui est
l'exception
dans les milieux que je fréquente il
semble pas que ce soit le cas dans les
milieux gouvernementaux qu'il
fréquentait encore récemment monsieur
royer mai
c'est un candidat du gouvernement il est
comme l'a dit d'ailleurs monsieur
messmer sarreguemines ya très peu de
temps il y à trois candidats de la
majorité ce que j'ai cité monsieur royer
mais je crois qu'il faut nécessaire de
rappeler aux gens un certain nombre de
choses monsieur loyal et l'autre jour
qu'il était pour le respect de la vie
mais enfin il était membre il ya une
quinzaine de jours du gouvernement qui a
déposé le projet de loi poniatowski sur
le bureau de l'assemblée nationale
projet de loi qui organise la
légalisation de l'avortement et il est
donc solidaires cette politique
je comprends pas qu'aujourd'hui il
vienne dire le contraire de ce que vous
avez un autre point commun avec monsieur
royer c'est que vous avez été élu la
première fois sous une étiquette de
défense des commerçants et des artisans
c'est exact mais vous savez les gens qui
espèrent et les gens qui prient qui
pensent que les commerçants les artisans
vous se déterminer en ce qui concerne
l'avenir de la france uniquement à
travers leur tiroir-caisse se font une
piètre opinion de cette catégorie de
citoyens que je connais bien et dont je
sais très bien qu'ils jugeront eux la
politique et les hommes qui leur sont
proposés en fonction des intérêts de la
france et en fonction de son avenir dans
votre programme j'ai remarqué
particulièrement vous insistez sur la
réforme de l'état et sur la réforme de
l'administration
les programmes politiques ne sont rien
s'ils ne sont pas appliqués
il reste au stade des promesses
électorales dont nous savons ce qu'elles
valent pour pouvoir appliquer une
politique et pour changer de politique
si les français désire véritablement ne
pas retomber dans les errements s'il
désire ne pas voir ce qui risque de se
voir demain c'est-à-dire l'affrontement
entre une france coupée en deux il faut
changer mais pour changer de politique
faut pouvoir l'appliquer
les mesures que je propose si elles sont
appliquées par un état impuissant comme
il est pléthorique
je vous rappelle que nous avons trois
millions 800 mille fonctionnaires qui
absorbe véritablement l'énergie de la
nation sans la rendre
et bien c'est impossible il faut donc
d'abord réformer l'instrument avec
lequel on va faire la nouvelle politique
cet instrument c'est l'état c'est
l'administration genre l'occasion
le mercredi soir de consacrer ma
prochaine émission spécialement à cette
partie de la réforme de l'état de la
politique étrangères et de la défense
nationale
autre poids prioritaire dans votre
programme vous donner davantage aux
problèmes des gens du 3e et l'écouté je
crois que avant toute chose quand une
situation est parfaitement injuste
il faut aller au plus pressé et si vous
voulez c'est une mesure à court terme
que je propose et c'est l'indexation des
pensions des retraites et des
allocations qui sont donnés aux
personnes du troisième âge pourquoi
parce que notre civilisation cruel et
semble éliminer les gens à partir du
moment où ils ont cessé de servir
or le troisième âge ce sont des français
comme les autres à qui nous sommes
redevables de notre liberté et de notre
prospérité qu'ils ont conquise et
transmises par leur travail et par leur
sacrifice
ils ont donc droit dans notre
collectivité a une par une par qui n'est
pas à l'écart dans des mouroirs on les
enverrait attendre l'issue finale
c'est pour ça que je préconise une
politique globale du troisième âge qui
les intègre véritablement à la vie
sociale et même à la vie économique où
beaucoup de gens s'ils le désirent même
dans l'app après leur retraite peuvent
rendre des services par un homme comme
conseiller les petites et moyennes
entreprises
voyez vous je crois que ce problème là
est un problème d'humanisation des
rapports sociaux et d'humanisation de la
vie les vieillards ou les vieilles
personnes les personnes âgées le
troisième âge n'ont pas seulement besoin
d'être nourris et logés
elles ont aussi besoin d'être aimé c'est
un problème de démoc
filles en général et d'écouter le
problème de démographie se pose en effet
à la france de manière aiguë est pour
pouvoir assurer aux gens du troisième
âge
c'est à dire nous demain et nous tous
une vie décente il faut qu'il y ait
suffisamment de français pour travailler
or le taux de natalité de la france est
en train de baisser dangereusement est
d'ores et déjà le petit avantage que
nous avons est constitué pour plus de la
moitié soit par l'immigration étrangère
soit par les naissances et projets alors
je dis et je lance un cri d'alarmé la
france
la démocratie la démographie française
est en péril et elle doit être préservé
c'est pour cela qu'il faut élaborer une
véritable politique familiale alors que
très précisément tout ce qu'on a fait
jusqu'à présent à considérer a consisté
plus exactement à abaisser la famille et
à la priver de ses ressources
je propose donc des mesures concrètes
pour que les chefs de famille père ou
mère qui sont comme l'a dit pays
les aventuriers du xxème siècle puisse
véritablement élever des enfants ce qui
est davantage de toute la france sans
que ce soit pour une charge écrase
je propose donc des mesures concrètes
une mesure fiscale
portait d'une demi part à une part le
dégrèvement fiscal parce que tout le
monde sait dans notre pays qu'un enfant
coûte aussi cher à entretenir une grande
personne et aussi les mesures en faveur
des mères de trois enfants qui vont
avoir un troisième enfant et quelques
autres sur lesquels ils pourront se
reporter dans mon programme mais alors
problème du financement parce que tout
cela coûte cher et ou dégagez vous les
crédits ben vous avez bien raison de
poser le problème du financement et
j'aurais dû peut-être en parler
auparavant
d'abord les mesures sociales et
économiques dont je parlais la semaine
prochaine je les financerait pas une
deuxième coupe sombre
d'abord dans les missions de l'état
n'est ce pas il faut que l'état se
débarrasse de ses missions économiques
il faut qu'ils se débarrassent de toute
une série de dépenses de prestige qui
sont financés par les français qui ne
leur servent pas tenez je vais vous
donner un exemple celui de concorde
concorde a coûté 14 milliards lourd
n'est ce pas c'est à dire 1400 milliards
et ne sera jamais très probablement
hélas qu'un grand jouer et bien en point
cela at il coûté aux français
eh bien le concorde très précisément
akuiteo a coûté à tous les français à
chaque famille française mille francs
lourd 100000 france c'est à dire le prix
de la machine à laver que l'invs et
celle que vous attendiez peut-être
maintenant alors je dis que il faut
faire des économies et cela financera
les le programme social et économique
que je préconise mais en ce qui concerne
très précisément la politique familiale
jeulin finance non point par cela mais
par l'excédent des caisses d'allocations
familiales qui se monte actuellement à 9
milliards en lourd 900 milliards
d'anciens francs et il y a largement de
quoi assumer les charges d'une politique
familiale et ce serait que justice car
il est bien juste mais c'est l'occasion
familiale aya famille vous avez été un
rapporteur du budget de la guerre à la
commission de la défense nationale
vous avez été officier vous avez servi
plusieurs fois je vais dire en indochine
et en algérie
on peut être surpris de vous voir
prendre une position d'hostilité par
rapport au service militaire
une pulsion d'hostilité c'est beaucoup
dire la défense nationale et la mission
fondamentale de l'armée l'armée dans un
pays est fait pour le protéger de
l'invasion étrangère
c'est un service ce service doit être
remplie de la manière la plus efficace
qui soit et la moins présente il est
inutile de faire un service si ça ne
sert à rien or les armées modernes met
en oeuvre des techniques des moyens
matériels extrêmement sophistiqué
extrêmement coûteux difficile à
maîtriser et il n'est pas possible de
former des personnels sur ces matériels
en n
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me suis
prononcé très nettement pour une armée
de métier convenablement rémunéré et
pour un service militaire volontaire
intensif de six mois le service
militaire était supportable quand il
était égale pour tous
ce n'est plus
depuis longtemps en effet il ya à peu
près un tiers des recrues qui ne font
pas leur service militaire en prétextant
je ne sais quel malaise physique on est
très large c'est sur ce plan là un autre
tiers fait son service militaire dans la
coopération en étant payés n'est ce pas
et dans des conditions qui ne savent pas
toujours le prestige national
ils le font parce qu'ils ont des
relations ils vont à l'étranger est
somme toute ne reste à faire le service
militaire auquel tiers de gens les gens
du peuple qui ne connaissent ni député
ni milice les peas agriculteurs les fils
de commerçants d'artisans d'ouvriers
cela pour un service militaire qui dans
les conditions actuelles
hélas les rentrer gens voient souvent
les renvoie dans leur famille pas
toujours très porté sur la solution des
responsabilités militaires alors je
crois qu'il faut faire cesser cette
inégalité et prendre des mesures qui
sont convenables moderne efficace
l'armée de métier c'est un danger c'est
l'armé de pretoria un jour ou l'autre
vous savez là je vais vous citer deux
pays qui ont des armées professionnelles
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas de service
militaire obligatoire de conscription
les états unis l'angleterre je ne sache
pas que ce sont des pays dont on discute
les règles démocratiques meilleur aussi
un point dans votre programme qui est
original et que personne ne vous
discutera je crois vous demandez pour
les forces de l'ordre le soutien de
l'opinion est bien écouter parce que je
pense qu'il est fondamental que l'ordre
règne dans un pays parce que le désordre
et l'anarchie c'est quand même une autre
forme d'or c'est là la dictature des
forces et la dictature des puissances et
la dictature des brutaux et je crois que
il n'y a pas et de liberté sans ordre et
qu' il est inconvenant que les forces de
l'ordre qui assume cette difficile tâche
difficile soit conspué ou méprisés et
non défendu par l'état voyez vous il y à
là et je crois une injustice dans cette
catégorie de citoyens et est la victime
et je crois qu'il est normal que les
fonctionnaires qui font leur métier soit
protégé dans l'exercice de leur métier
vous savez les français aiment voir
guignols battre le gendarme
et puis il arrive un jour le gendarme
est fatigué d'être battus et s'en va et
à ce moment là les citoyens se
retrouvent en tête à tête avec les
bandits et c'est une autre affaire
pensez-vous particulièrement l'ordre
dans les universités dans les lycées où
je parle de l'ordre dans tout le pays
je reviendrai sur la question de
l'université qui est une question
fondamentale puisque elle tient l'avenir
de tout le pays
mais vous voyez bien que le désordre non
de banditisme la criminalité et il n'est
pas possible de ne pas faire quelque
chose sous peine de voir sombrer le pays
dans l'anarchie la guerre civile il ya
beaucoup d'autres points dans votre
programme mais je voudrais vous demander
puisque nous n'aurons pas le temps
aujourd'hui de tous les voix de choisir
ce qui vous semble le plus important
dans l'immédiat et d'écouté j'ai dit que
je consacrerai ma prochaine émission
mercredi soir à aux questions de l'étang
n'est ce pas et de l'administration et
les problèmes économiques et sociaux la
semaine prochaine lundi prochain je
crois que c'est à midi je traiterai
d'autres problèmes en particulier
l'école l'immigration étrangère et toute
une série de problèmes capitaux pour
l'avenir des français et non politique
étrangère l'alliance atlantique est bien
coté en politique étrangère je pense que
la france doit mener sa politique pour
garder une réelle indépendance avec ceux
qui sont ses alliés naturels c'est à
dire d'abord ses alliés européens et
bien sûr ses alliés de l'alliance
atlantique au moment où l'urss masse des
trous très importante au plan classique
et atomique
je crois que la liberté des français la
sécurité de la france ne peuvent être
rassurés qu'avec ses amis ses véritables
l'europe par exemple et de porc et bien
sûr l'europe
il faut pousser la coopération
européenne et l'inclure je crois dans
une forme réaliste et je crois que ce
qui serait important de faire tout de
suite avant toute chose c'est la
confédération européenne qui aurait à sa
disposition une politique étrangère une
politique militaire et peut-être une
politique monétaire commune
c'est cette forme de coopération qui je
crois peut le mieux protéger notre
prospérité et notre libre
quelle est la place dans cette
confédération européenne des régions eh
bien voyez-vous je pense que je suis un
adversaire inutile de vous dire des
séparatismes à l'intérieur de la france
mais je pense que la région doit jouer
son rôle et qu'on doit je pense en
particulier à ma bretagne natale et
qu'on doit favoriser autant que faire se
peut la vie culturelle
la diversité est très enrichissante de
nos différentes régions françaises
je crois que ça ne va pas du tout
al'inverse d'un patriotisme que je ne
laisserai pas je dois vous le dire
atteindre donc vous êtes un candidat de
droite et vous êtes aussi opposés aux
boulistes qu'au communisme
exactement je suis la troisième solution
je suis candidate d'une droite qui est
social populaire et nationale mais parce
que la situation est grave
je propose un programme de salut public
que je demande à tous les français et à
toutes les françaises de juger en leur
âme et conscience avant de rendre le
verdict de dimanche
en quinze celui public donc danger très
proche eh bien je crois que la france
est menacée je crois que actuellement on
essaye de le lui faire oublier la crise
énergétique qui est des matières
premières vous le savez mettre notre
économie en péril et tout le monde sent
bien même si on essaie d'effacer star
pendant la campagne électorale qu'il y à
de très graves menaces sur l'emploi et
que beaucoup de français sont guettés
par le chômage et je dis que ce n'est
pas le moment de faire des promesses
inconsidérées
c'est le moment pour les français de se
resserrer autour d'un véritable
programme de gouvernement capable de
leur éviter ces dangers qu un jour merci
alors donc vous retrouverez les audits
les téléspectateurs mercredi mais
mercredi soir de votre programme c'est
ça bonsoir et merci